welcome to the MIT communications forum
we have a really exciting forum for you
today we're very excited to have our
speakers here first of all my name is
Cristina couch I'm the program
administrator for the forum here we
wanted to warn you please no flash
photography during this event our event
is being taped and there will be a video
an audio recording available on our
website before we get started I wanted
to introduce our moderator this evening
she's the associate professor of
literature here at MIT
she's also assistant director of our
communications forum and author of
artful Dodgers Rican sieving the Golden
Age of children's literature
please welcome Margo Barr thank you so
much and thank you so much for coming
so our format today as per usual with
the calm form is very conversational and
so I have some questions for the
panelists and we'll talk until about six
o'clock and then and either of you can
feel free to chime into it at any time
if you have a thought and then we'll
open to the floor to your questions
we'll open the floor to your questions
at 6:00 or so okay so first I'm gonna
ask our panelists actually to introduce
themselves and tell us each a little bit
about who they are and their work and
how their career is related to the theme
of women in politics so Marianne will
you start I'm Mary Anne Marsh I'm a
woman in politics I work I'm a principal
at the Dewey Square group was just a
democratic consulting firm we're best
known for we're the preeminent firm in
grassroots campaigns before grassroots
was cool we did grassroots and I also
and my political analyst for and up here
on the Fox News Channel as a Democrat I
do wcvb here in Boston I do WBZ radio as
well Sky News in London and my perhaps
one of my favorites the radio New
Zealand is very big and so I've done
tons of campaigns for longer than I want
to admit and they've worked with male
and female candidates along the way and
you know look forward to discussing all
that with you this evening thank you so
much and
Ellen I'm Ellen Emerson white and I make
up stories about these things it's not I
don't have any TV shows I don't have any
pundit experience but when I was going
to Tufts I've heard a book about the
daughter of the first female president a
little realizing that many years later
not that many we'd like to pretend to be
just won't go into the details but we
still don't have one Wow go figure
so for books about the same character
and a lot of research on endemic depth
behind it but I can't pretend to be a
political expert because you know
stories jokes entertainment and fun the
year the president's daughter came out
right yeah I was a toddler of course but
the old were you well it's gonna date me
considerably but I sold I was 19 when I
wrote the president's daughter I
finished it when I was 20 it came out
when I was yes
a year later so don't do the math here
at MIT and you're probably very good at
math geraldine ferraro got nominated two
months after the book came out so it was
a good timing and everything looked very
promising as far as our actual American
political system and yes many years past
them yeah I saw what didn't happen
Maryann why do you think it's taken so
long it's a great question right I mean
I think to Ellen's point I am I got an
honorary degree at my alma mater two
years ago and part of that speech was I
never thought it would after all these
years there still wouldn't have been a
woman elected to the presidency
inconceivable especially in you know
electing Barack Obama first as an
african-american president terrific
great wonderful but the fact that we
haven't elected a woman yet says a lot
and when you look at across politics I
mean women are 51 52 % of the population
and a fraction of Congress a fraction of
the governor's a fraction of state
legislatures up and down the political
system there are barely any women by
comparison and it's true in business as
I mean when you look at CEOs and you
know sitting on boards and all that
stuff that says a lot and I think there
are lots of reasons for it but it's hard
to ignore the fact that often times less
qualified men be very qualified women on
both sides both as Democrats and
Republicans and I think that's a lot to
grapple with I think we may have the
chance again to watch that sort of
referendum a year from now pretty much
you know in 51 and a half weeks and to
see whether it seems so much longer I
know it well and I think there are a
multitude of reasons cultural I think
religion into it and go across economics
all of it and I think one big difference
I see constantly in campaigns is when
men run they only have to deal with
their assets or challenges as
individuals when women run for office
they represent the entire gender
everything good or bad in top of to on
top of their individual assets or
deficiencies and I think that's a very
big challenge and I will leave you on
this note for now once again it probably
came it's no surprise but last night you
know we had a Republican debate again
you know the undercard the big debate
and at the end of the debate on Drudge
which I don't know how many people here
know about The Drudge Report but it's a
website that feeds lots of news out
there and the featured thing on Drudge
was Hillary Clinton's hair okay and then
the Google map of her hairdresser and
where her salon is and what's going on
with her hair and all this stuff and and
so I feel like in this case you see that
constant I've had I've had clients who
had the same challenges you know Hillary
Clinton nobody covered more nobody
vetted more nobody challenged more and
no one whose hair has been discussed
more than anybody and this earth and
here we are in 2015 and that's exactly
what was on the front page of Drudge so
I think that says a lot yeah
my goodness so what and it was an unkind
photo that's it
there was some attempt there but the one
on the top would yeah yeah
oh my good manner that Yellen do you
want to do the honors yes yes my father
is a retired professor he would be
appalled by my lack of mentioning it
1984 Walter Mondale was not going to win
the election against Myrna Bregenz so
Geraldine Ferraro was a congresswoman
from Queens and she was nominated to be
his vice president and it got pretty
ugly because her father was real estate
in New York which if you were from New
York you know tends to be a complicated
business and she was really sad and she
don't remember the press conference you
know i yeah and it was a very it's a
very strange day I mean it was exciting
but I don't think anyone I wasn't paying
attention thought there was any chance
they were going to and when you tried to
sell the president's daughter your
editor told you it wasn't realistic
right two years earlier they said no
one's no one's gonna read this
you can't possibly make it remotely
plausible to have a woman running yeah
yeah and the interesting thing about the
books over the years as I was telling
you is no one has ever mentioned that
she's a woman ever done reviewing on the
conversation they criticize her as a
president
god no they criticize her as a mother
they never criticize her outfits cuz she
dresses a far better than I ever will
but yeah I never came up that she was a
woman cuz I've worked really hard to
create the most plausible candidate with
the background that I thought was
electable and were you inspired by
actual female politicians had you any
contact in politics before what gave you
the urge to write this was it a was it a
feminist desire to see that in the world
or like where did it come from that's
better than going to class
no there was nothing out there no pop
culture I came there had been one movie
and I am I did not see this movie
because it was 1964 but I caught up with
it later called kisses for my president
starring uh Polly Bergen I was nodding
you saw a little bit it was pulling
because she's elected president and she
serves and then Fred MacMurray is her
husband and he gets her pregnant and she
steps down because she has a baby and
that's true a key to be President and
that's the end of the movie it's
supposed to be a happy ending and so
that was the only pop culture female
president when I was writing the book
and there was one book Jeffrey Archer
two books Jeffrey Archer had done the
prodigal daughter and shall we tell the
president and not a likeable president
and Steve Dunleavy had done the very
first first lady where she was
Machiavelli and him very very scary and
that book tanked but the archer book did
well and that was it no I have no idea
like I was gonna major in political
science and then drama and then English
and then drop out of it you know mostly
I went to movies to tell you the truth
but um Red Sox games it was pretty much
me in college I read books okay but
there was absolutely nothing out there
and I had sold two other books to a New
York publisher about other things and
when I came to them with this idea they
just we can't possibly make money on
that
no and it's ironic too because it's a
very realistic series in many ways right
you know so it's I think yeah it
definitely is
yeah except for that part yeah so were
you intentionally planning to write it
as Y a as a young adult literature or no
you just wrote it and then they told you
it was Y a
did that work I was 19 you were young
and I was 19 so I you know the main
character was a junior in high school
what do you yeah I do remember I went
after the president's daughter came out
did pretty well and they had me go to a
speaking thing and I got there early and
it's very very crowded and it was a lot
of women my mother's age and I was shy
and I was just sitting in the corner
with my coffee kind of swinging my legs
and the editor came in and they're like
where's the writer the writer never
showed it's supposed to be starting and
the other thing um she's right there
sitting there they all turn around the
entire room their faces fell and they
said oh you're the kids age what you're
worth the president's age we thought it
would be real and then they apologized
and they were nice and I gave my little
talk in the whole nine yards but they
were very upset that I was the age of
the main character I mean the president
is her mother so it's a different thing
but yeah they were really hoping it had
come out of the ER a was still in the
air then and I still can't believe they
didn't pass the ara fortunately every
college kid I know right now is pretty
big on feminism so I'm hoping things me
maybe maybe would get another chance for
that one that's interesting is that your
sense too as someone who advises
candidates about younger yeah I mean I
do think younger students tend to be
more progressive today I think you saw
that in the Obama campaign you certainly
see that in this campaign cycle
certainly not only with Clinton but
certainly with Sanders in particular I
think what worries me is that I think a
lot of younger students and others
especially women I think take don't take
seriously the real threat to things like
abortion abortion rights and a lot of
other issues that I think really are at
risk this election cycle and are at risk
at the state level and a whole other
bunch of things that at least we're old
enough to remember that that wasn't
always the case
hmm and I think what a lot of younger
women take a lot of those things for
granted and don't realize that wasn't
always the way and like this could go in
this election cycle and I think you also
note that especially on the Republican
side the disdain for Supreme Court
rulings they don't like presidential you
know executive orders they don't like
bills that are passed that they don't
like and just decide to ignore so I love
the enthusiasm and progressive views of
younger voters and younger students and
I love the energy they bring to
campaigns and we covet them all but that
is one concern I have mm-hmm yeah I mean
I wonder - I don't know my own
experience teaching is that often people
don't want to identify as a feminist
like do you know what I mean which it
always puzzles me slightly and I'm
wondering if this is what how we connect
this to the to the question of like why
has it taken so long and you know what
kind of special challenges female
candidates face you know so can you tell
us give us some like actual like
particular stories of campaigns where
you saw like sexism being a factor I
mean they're endless I mean it's from
the the most basic things to the really
obvious thing so let me let me split
them in half okay working with a
candidate every time I work with a woman
candidate I only do this with women
right let me look at your clothes let's
look at your wardrobe how do I like your
hair what color is your hair should we
should change your hair you know me it's
all about appearances first and foremost
because women still are judged on them
much more almost exclusively to the fact
that men aren't so you have whether you
like it or not you have to do it because
you don't want that to be an issue you
want people to focus on what's being
said what you're you know supporting
what your positions are but you have to
get by that first so you can't give
voters an excuse so I mean with male
candidates
I mean I'll care about a tie maybe you
know like what color shirt what color
you know but not to the great extent
right that you do with women it's it's a
full-time job in that
expect or making sure they have makeup
and hair done and all that before
debates and all those things men do it
too and you'd be and most of them do
maybe no one pays attention to that as
much and then on the other side of it
there are things from male moderators at
debates who ask questions that are
worded in a way - a woman candidate
again on abortion and others that are
stunning and jaw-dropping and and yet
they're insistent that this is the way
it is think what do you mean well I'd go
back to for example I hate speaking of
people who are no longer with us because
I don't a chance to defend themselves
right but there was a debate with a
former client of mine Shannon O'Brien
who was you know ran for governor
against Mitt Romney I had worked with
her when she ran for treasurer believe
it or not in Massachusetts and when she
was elected she was the first woman ever
elected to statewide office in
Massachusetts in the night it took us to
the 90s to do that Wow okay everyone
thinks Massachusetts this is great
progressive bastions right it is not I
mean Elizabeth Warren I think has helped
that immensely and a lot of women have
gotten elected since she won the Senate
race and that was brutal but you know
Tim Russert moderated a debate between
Mitt Romney and Shannon O'Brien and he
went after her and abortion like I
cannot tell you and it was jaw-dropping
and that was a turning point in that
race on that exchange on that topic and
I'll point to two others one both have
to do with Hillary Clinton if you go
back to when Hillary Clinton ran for the
Senate in New York and she had a debate
with Rick Lazio and there was the famous
exchange when Rick Lazio went over to
her with a piece of paper walked over to
her she's at one podium he's at the
other walks across puts this in front of
it says sign this sign this sign this
now I want you to sign this pledge well
that was the turning point in that race
because every woman who saw that said oh
my god that's my husband with the credit
card bill I can't believe this I mean he
was it was just so unbelievable re
Clinton for Senate fast forward to a few
weeks ago and Hillary Clinton comes out
and talks about gun control and how
important it is and all that Bernie
Sanders then says just
shouting about gun control isn't enough
it's not going to change it and in this
case a lot of women and Hillary Clinton
said why did you say shouting what is
shouting have to do with it she's not
shouting and she then used that line
herself in several forms saying you know
what when a women should when a woman
shouts she's not shouting she's actually
trying to get something done in saying
it so even someone as progressive as
Bernie Sanders here we are in 2015 you
know those aren't small things people
pick up on them so I think that's
something worth noting yeah and you hear
the words shout was a gentle one shrill
yeah cackle you know those are the nice
ones
yeah I know you know things people say
it that's kind of ugly and but the thing
that troubles me and I will throw it
back on the voters is I can't even tell
you how many times I've talked to
someone about a female candidate for any
office and had them said oh I don't for
a woman just write that well right and
then another woman comes along totally
different absolutely different and he
said well what about her I'd vote for a
woman and after why me you know more
than one friend I've called out on this
so what woman would you vote for and
they all say Oh Katherine powers we vote
for her okay she's imaginary she's made
up what a real woman on the planet would
you vote for yeah I mean if Eleanor
Roosevelt were here now they wouldn't
vote for her they would have plenty of
complaints but she would be strident
that would be the word they would give
her I think and it's just the most
encouraging thing to me that's happened
in politics recently is in Canada they
just put together a 50-50 cabinet this
never happened can you imagine here if
we had a 50/50 cabin 50% women 50% men
and they hit all kinds of different
religious just a thought this the avid
Hebrew God loving me made a point of
getting ever
Canadian represented but we've never
seen that in America or even anything
close to 50% how could we get closer do
you think I mean I think part of it is
take some of the money I don't have it
could help a little bit
women women have always had a harder
time raising money for a lot of reasons
because they don't have the political
contacts or the business contacts now
you have super PACs and we're talking
about that a little bit before we
started this I think culture is a large
part of it seeing women in those roles
in culture whether it's in books or in
movies or TV or other forms I think just
electing more women helps more women get
elected because women see people in
those roles and I mean Elizabeth Warren
winning here really opened up the lid I
mean that Katherine Clark then followed
her I mean we've elected you know more
Healy then came in as a you know there
are a lot of women now who are finally
winning in Massachusetts and across the
country but it takes it takes a big
effort a lot bigger than it would for
anything else so I think the more women
are seen in those roles the bigger
difference it's gonna make mm-hmm mm-hmm
um do women candidates I feel like I'm
trying to think about a happy question
like do they have certain advantages as
candidates that as opposed to men yeah I
mean when you look at polling and focus
groups vote ironically which is the
here's the big disconnect people tend to
trust women more they believe them when
they say something so anyone who runs
for office the four steps you have to go
through is that people have to get to
know you and like you first and foremost
then they have to believe what you're
saying and the last piece is trust right
so that's why you always hear the word
trust at the end of every election do I
trust that person to do what they say
they're gonna do so they trust women
when they women say they're gonna do
something they believe and trust that
women will actually get it done mm-hmm
they also believe that women are more
likely to work together with other
people men work with women work with
Democrats work with Republicans and you
actually see that with the women
senators in the United States Senate
they all go to dinner every six weeks
together Democrats and Republicans they
all work on each other
Bill's together even if they don't agree
on things they will work together Susan
Collins Lisa Murkowski will work with
Kirsten Gillibrand or Elizabeth Warren
on things and compromise to actually get
things done that's how it used to be
with everybody so I think the more that
those things are seen and they all
support each other in these efforts and
they go on book tours together and do
all kinds of things together I think the
more people see that the better it is
but until you win that top slot until a
woman gets elected president I think
that will help to open up the floodgates
more but it's gonna be very tough to do
very tough
yeah well which is maybe why it's good
at least we have it in fiction right at
least we have Ellen giving us
Catherine Vaughn powers so let me ask
you a question Ellen well I mean I can
this is severe toward the sad right in
the sense that what happens during the
Vaughan presidency the Vaughan powers
presidency is is a lot of traumatic
stuff goes down so can you tell people
who haven't read the series give them a
little sense of some of the stuff that
happens in just say for me being a bad
writer you know yes plodding I'm weak
but Aaron Sorkin did it on the west wing
- you're trying to tell a bigger story
but you need people to tune in so Jeff
Bartlett gets shot she gets I mean I did
it 20 years before I don't think he
copied me it's just what we do and there
is a kidnapping you know god forbid such
a thing would ever happen in the real
world but it was where I wanted to go
with fiction the thing I find sort of
more disturbing I'm just jumping to a
slightly different topic for a second
okay because I was going over female
presidents in pop culture I was watching
some of the shows in the movies and just
doing some research this week thinking
about it almost none of them were
elected on their own almost every single
one of them and think about any female
president you've ever seen
the president dies she takes over its
vice president they're not happy to have
her maybe she should resign maybe she
shouldn't take office she didn't
actually win her husband dies she gets
she inherits a seat she ends up
president all kinds of in the case of
the the one great in my opinion we were
talking about this female president I
think in pop culture has been Bora
Rosalyn on Battlestar Galactica which
you if you have not watched you really
must awesome show yes but Laura Roslin
is everything you want in a president
and it helps when you choose an Academy
award-winning actor to play the part
it's gonna be that much better but even
in Laura Roslin's case they had to blow
up everybody else and she's something
crazy I can't remember where she is in
succession she's way back I want yeah
but but I can't member the number is it
like 80th or something or whatever she
is she's way back but she happened to be
on the ship because they were
decommissioning the ship when the world
blow up by the Cylons really good job so
even she didn't earn it I think on 24
when Jerry Jones played that president I
think she was elected an actual
honest-to-god election but nope
president died commander in chief yeah
not a huge favorite of mine but I like
Geena Davis mm-hmm but she was asked to
step down and not assume office so that
Donald Sutherland may be Speaker of the
House who played it like snidely
whiplash could take the role so why is
that she's like well I think it is
people have trouble imagining the
reality of a woman who works her way up
through the trenches and gives up a lot
because you can't have it all we all
know this there are things you're going
to have to give up if you do that there
are sacrifices you'll make
the core of my books about the female
president I think she's a good mother
actually I really do but her family has
taken most of the blows from her Abby
she starts off she's from Massachusetts
she starts off in the assembly she gets
a congressional seat she ends up in the
Senate I think she's one of the deputy
whips when she's in Congress and she
jumps to Senate and then suddenly in the
first book keep him in mind I was only
19 they want her to run because she
appears to be viable they do not want
her to win and she actually doesn't
really want to win either it comes as a
bit of a surprise to her that she
actually won the election and but she
does it the old-fashioned it's the whole
thing she goes through the primary she
goes through this I did did a little bit
of a brokered convention because I just
I did I thought it'd be more
entertaining in the book I like to think
that wouldn't actually happen but I was
amazed when I went through pop culture
that I could not find examples of in
fiction in it and most of the female
presidents we've seen have been sitcoms
there was hail to the chief with Patty
Duke back in the day honestly we had
feet but now most of the books have been
science fiction it's um another world
mm-hmm
you know copal or you know whatever so
not real presidents you haven't had a
lot of American ones and you really
haven't had a lot in any foreign home
ran for office important and if you
can't I do think you kind of need to
when you watch The West Wing we see the
campaign we see the primaries we see
that you know we see all the steps and
if that had been done with a woman you
know say that was played by Stockard
Channing and he was the hard-working
partner it would have been have we been
groundbreaking for television to watch
that and we just we haven't seen it and
I think in America there's a little bit
of a tendency if you've seen it ie
Donald Trump maybe you want to vote for
and if you haven't seen in you can't
imagine it it becomes a little bit more
of an imaginary story mm-hmm Marianne
how did you decide did you do head were
you familiar with any of these
representations was that what got you
interested in politics in the first
place did you want to be a politician
yourself how did you get into political
consulting and punditry
I've always loved politics I mean for as
long as I can remember and I don't know
how I know that but I always did decided
not to go to law school probably the
best decision I ever made
despite applying multiple times and
getting in and deferring and all that I
just I loved campaigns I still do and
that's what I love the most is you know
working on them and helping elect people
and all that the the pondered tree piece
was total happenstance more than
anything like that was not part of the
plan way back at one point I think like
so many people you think you're gonna
run yourself someday and I'm just gonna
learn how to do these campaigns on know
how to do mine
and plenty of people do that but I came
to the decision that I thought I could I
would be I would do a better job helping
a lot of people get elected and that
would be my contribution and there's
nothing better than honestly working on
a campaign and winning nothing better
and there's nothing worse than losing
and the analysis piece is just it's been
that was serendipity but I do think not
to I do think people who do analysis who
are good are the people who've done
campaigns there are a lot of people on
TV now and elsewhere who are reporters
or columnist soar opinion writers what
have you that have never worked on a
campaign they cover them they think they
know them but unless you work in them
you don't and I've been very fortunate I
think I'm my batting average is pretty
good because I know what it takes to
work on a campaign I know what it takes
to win you know the different cycles of
a campaign and what has to happen to be
successful or not so for me having that
knowledge makes me a far more accurate
and analyst on TV or what have you then
a lot of a lot of people give their
opinions and I'm on with people who give
a lot of opinions but when it comes to
the actual campaign and especially in a
presidential year
unless you've done campaigns and you
know not just a pretty unless you've
done any campaigns and a presidential
campaign because they're you know
they're all hard and kind of a different
beast you understand them and you know
what the next stages and what's coming
and what needs to be done and all that
even in a crazy year like this where
you're watching we're all watching a
race unfold that has never been seen
before by anybody in modern history and
may never be seen again and it's only
gonna get even more epically crazy over
the next year given how everybody feels
about and we're you know we were talking
about this before I mean when you have
24 million people 23 million people 13.5
million people watching debates in a
primary with a year to go that tells you
a lot that how people feel about this
election how people feel about the
country how the people feel about
Washington how they feel about Wall
Street and yes Donald Trump's a big part
of that and drawing people to it but
it's a lot more than that because even
the Democratic forint first debate there
were more people who watch that than
watch the very last debate between
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama in
April of 2008 and at that point no one
really knew which one of them was going
to get the nomination it was pretty
close more people have watched these two
days than watch that one so that tells
you a lot right there and and so even
though can I said I can remember saying
this the crack of dawn yesterday morning
on a radio interview
even though conventional wisdoms out the
window and everything about this
election isn't if achill to everything
else you've ever seen and you have to
view it that way still knowing what
campaigns do in work makes a big
difference yeah and is the punditry
world also uneven in terms of gender
like are there way more men than women
well I mean that's true of everything
right so so there are more male
reporters right and then women there are
more male bylines than women they're
more on air male talent talent than
women or host shows or our analysts or
on the sunday shows so you're what you
we view politics and and campaigns
through the largely through the eyes of
men not exclusively
but mostly there are more women now than
there used to be but we're nowhere close
to what it should be and that everyone
brings to it a perspective and a
viewpoint and you know I know a lot of
reporters and I have great relationships
with all of them and enjoy all but
everyone brings the everyone brings
their perspective to it and I think
that's certainly one of the interesting
things watching the media cover women
candidates versus male candidates and
including the Senate races here when
Coakley was up against Brown Warren was
up against Brown and a lot of what went
on there and even what we're watching
now so so you know journalists are I
think we all try to be objective I as a
Democrat on foxy as I am critical of
Democrats when they make mistakes or
they make a dumb decision or whatever I
will say that but I think it's hard to
provide a prism into politics and into
what you see without bringing your own
personal views to it no matter how
objective you try to be and if you
accept that premise then you know there
are different biases and skewing going
on to watching what's going on if you
only consume media and I in one last
point and this drove me crazy
recently Bernie Sanders had a rally here
right in Boston and everyone reported
that there were 16,000 people there
20,000 people there one person said
24,000 people so I actually go to these
things right so I went over to the
Seaport and I went to ganon I went into
the Seaport and there are three they
have a three about four bombs there in
each one holds 4,000 people they only
had one open the others were closed so
if you were indoors that was four
thousand people there then they opened
up an area cut by the lawn on D that too
held 4,000 people how do I know that I
asked the Boston police officers so
we're there with the clickers right and
I asked the security people who work the
building because that's how you find out
how many people
these things so there were actually
8,000 people there not 16 not 20 not 24
8 and yet everybody reported 16,000 or
20,000 and so I contacted two reporters
who I knew were there and I said where'd
you get this number
I said well we got it from the campaign
I said didn't you not ask the police did
you not ask the security no no no we did
we just took the number we were given
and that if you go back and look after
we finished this every media outlet in
the country use that number every single
one so there's there's a I'm not beating
up on the media per se but there's you
have to obviously we all use it
obviously I'm a small part of it but if
you want to really understand what's
going out on in politics go find out
yourself and one of the great things
about being in Massachusetts is go to
New Hampshire there is nothing better
than the in Hampshire primary it is the
greatest thing in politics and it's not
even an hour away and people there take
it very seriously and they pick
presidents so if you really want to know
what's going on I mean great story quick
story I do a Sunday show for channel 5
we had Niki Tsongas this morning as our
guest congresswoman from Massachusetts
and her husband Paul Tsongas ran for
president she told the story this
morning on the air and said that she had
a Paul Tsongas for president button on
as she's going through the tolls in New
Hampshire because they were going to
another place this is when he's run
against Clinton they stopped gave the
money this is before EZ Pass to the
person taking the tolls and the person
taking the tolls Lee and she goes oh do
you know Paul Tsongas and she said yes
as a matter of fact he's my husband she
goes that's great I have his book I'm
gonna read his book before I go see him
on Tuesday and before I vote next week
that's what everybody in New Hampshire
does and that's great so go find out for
yourself like don't believe me or other
people go find out for yourself what's
going on in the world now especially in
politics yeah and it's really exciting
yeah like you're saying about campaign
work it's really it's got a lot of
inherent drama built in that you can
capitalize on as a writer too right yeah
yeah so what do you think Ellen about
like I'm thinking about Kathryn Ron
powers as a
as a character and Hillary Clinton as
our actual candidate do you have any
thoughts about about similarities and
differences they fare very different so
different yeah I live in New York and I
know a bunch of people who know Hillary
I do not know Hillary although I've
heard her skin person a number of times
and they all talk about what she's
actually like and it just doesn't
translate along the time she never to me
feels comfortable in her skin she's
actually had a pretty good three weeks
in my opinion but like right now she's
finally getting on her game but Hillary
has always been just a little uncle was
cuz when she was born kind of right when
everything began to change it's worth
caught between Jenna rate I mean if
she'd been born ten years later 20 years
later I don't think she ever marries
Bill but you know I think it's just a
different thing Hillary just I think the
Clintons are so unique to anyone else in
the world you can possibly present the
president I know everybody's pretty
traditional political path nothing too
unusual and you know I'd like to think
she's funny no and she's you know she
seems more accessible to me mm-hmm then
and you know Hillary has just always
been for this particular time in our
history with so much noise like I'm
finding a treat at this moment I don't
exactly know where my phone is
I'm glad I'm not looking at anything I'm
not you know turn the phone off
sometimes the best thing that just ever
happened to you but right now watching
the Obama presidency been a lot of noise
the noise of all kinds all day every day
everyone has an opinion and just I don't
think he's as good at shutting him out
shutting it out hilary has been getting
this garbage for 30 Hertz for however
long it's been I just think she's a
would be a very good president for these
times but I think she would be capable
of just going the Oval Office shutting
the door and getting her work done
leaving the rest of us alone which is
kind of what I'm looking for for
president you know just we want jobs we
want we want not to be fighting wars
there there are things we want and it's
like a little bit of peace just not this
really the last 15 years of the these
two presidencies there's been it was
never polarized like this you know when
the old days chip O'Neil and Ron Reagan
soon together having drinks together see
it didn't used to be that if you had a
different opinion you were a bad person
and then we've gotten to this weird
place where if I disagree with you I
think you're evil you know it's like wow
what's up with that the whole point to
democracy is lively conversation leading
to consensus and compromise and that's
how things work and we're in this awful
I don't know how we're gonna get you
would need an incredibly charming and
charismatic and relaxed easy-going
president to get back to that and I
think I think we're ways away from that
right now we need someone do we think
complicit in in the state of affairs or
or a cause a causal factor I mean I
think social media has accelerated
everything if you go back to first cable
right which was the 24/7 we used to have
news cycles now it's a never-ending hose
that runs and then you throw in Twitter
and Facebook and Instagram and snapchat
and everything else it's never ending
never ending never and it happens all
the time and news breaks you know on
your phone especially in politics on
Twitter all the time 24/7 and so I think
that has accelerated everything and it's
all so amped everything up because
everybody has a voice everyone always
had a voice but you only had certain
places that you could use your voice you
could vote you know you could write a
letter to the editor quaint notion you
know you could do a few other things
but you know I have I do Fox News every
Monday morning and before I'm off the
air my Twitter feed blows up usually not
good but and people will find an email
for me at work or whatever and I find a
lot of times they're really brutal
frankly and oftentimes I reply to them
and I find that the people I reply to I
don't reply to everybody they're always
shocked to hear from me because I think
they think they're anonymous that
there's no consequence to what they say
or do they think they can just put it
out there on Twitter or say something
about you and nothing's gonna be done
about it and I always reply thank you
very much for watching thank you for
taking the time to write if there's
profanity involved I asked them to write
me back without it and that's how you
know let's have a conversation a debate
or whatever and that usually works so I
think that's a large part of it and I
think candidates in particular if you've
been around for a while are used to
things being very different and not used
to having an iPhone on you all the time
trackers on you all the time as I said
you know google maps showing where your
hairdresser you know in Chappaqua you
know where her salon is I mean all those
things I think it amps everything up and
it's sort of like politics on steroids
and I think it's that's always a it's
always a hard beast to manage and your
job is to try to manage it always as a
candidate as a campaign but it just it's
so big now and it's so fast and I think
that adds also to your point hardened
people's opinions so if you if you have
a set of opinions you're just not open
to hearing anybody else's ideas you know
if you're a conservative Republican who
just believes that Barack Obama Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders are the
Antichrist you can't be persuaded
otherwise and and and I would say the
same of people on the left - so it's
made that kind the ability to have a
conversation difficult let alone work
out deals and compromises when a lot of
people on the left and right don't
believe you should have them and and
then just one thing to your point if if
you go back to the Hillary Clinton of
the late 80s early 90s
like when her hon bill clinton was
running for re-election as governor or
when he was running for president the
first time that hillary clinton in this
environment would walk away with this
race okay would walk away with it she
was much more althought sharp on the
ball willing to say anything challenge
anybody i mean just go back and look at
her like during the 92 election for
example in the statement she made or
being a surrogate for her husband we was
running for reelection
in Arkansas that person there would be
no contest right now I think what has
happened over the years is when you are
subjected to a beating by the media and
others all these years you start to get
a little carrot pace yeah and yeah and
but I think she's starting to hit her
stride because now she's out there doing
more and I think you know that's also
the Jeb Bush problem is Jeb Bush is just
not performing well as a candidate and
you can have the best ads and the best
campaigns but if your candidates not
performing on the stump and when they
meet people and we were talking about
this earlier you know the super PAC for
Jeb Bush has spent over 16 million
dollars just around here lately on ads
and his poll numbers have dropped not
gone up used to be able to buy five
points right with a TV ad or two right
you put some money in New Hampshire put
them in Boston that was like a good five
points you can maybe get ten now because
the ads showed Jeb Bush one way and yet
everybody who meets Jeb Bush in New
Hampshire 15 times because they pride
themselves on that that's not the person
they see so that the the real person the
reality versus the the perception of
that that's put on TV aren't the same
and so when you have a candidate who
just does not perform and does not
connect with people you're not gonna win
that race because who's gonna vote for
somebody they don't like if you don't
like somebody you're never gonna get to
trust them right you're never gonna get
through those four steps and I think
that's what you see right now in if you
would use that measure you can size up
pretty much where everybody is in this
race hmm really interesting yeah I yes
well I think it's I wish I'm a big
Elizabeth Warren
I really like her and one thing I think
she's someone I wish you were running
but I don't have a problem of Hillary I
will be supporting Hillary but a thing
that is very appealing about someone
like Elizabeth Warren for these chances
when she said something no matter what
it is I believe her
yeah I believe she is saying what she
thinks I may not agree with it in her
case I usually do but there's a real
appeal people just you know world it's
probably no one in this room who isn't
old enough to vote maybe a couple of you
are prodigies and guarding when you were
15 and maybe you can't vote yet but
probably you can all vote so we're all
grown-ups don't you just want someone to
tell you the truth like don't you want
someone to say while we got into
Afghanistan this big old mess and I
don't know how we're gonna get out and
we're gonna you know just tell you tell
you the truth saying okay we passed this
healthcare we did our best some of it
doesn't work we need to go we do not
need to get rid of it we just need to
change a few things we need to have less
narrow networks we need to do this but
let's all work to get like Elizabeth
Warren talks and I just think she spent
years studying this she spent countless
hours probably lying on the couch in
their house staring at the ceiling
thinking about it and now when she
speaks it I totally believe her I don't
think you jerking us around
and it's we were talking about Trump
because I happen to know a bunch of
people I played softball for years in
Central Park we might we won the city
championship one year like six years ago
we were very impressive and my name is
spelled wrong and the trophy I'm not
bitter but almost all the people work
for Trump they're all like Democrats and
and mostly Latino and I said that they
love the man and you know I've heard so
many good things about him you're kind
of thinking okay I must adjust my mind
to see that he's probably kind man but I
think part of the appeal to a guy like
him is you think he's telling you what
he thinks
whether you agree with it whether you
think it's stupid what it is yeah it in
fact I think he hurt himself a little
inside baseball here perhaps
I thought he'd hurt himself a little in
the last debate because it's starting to
become clear that he now has handlers
hmm and he's now he is starting to sound
more like a politician and that's why I
think he's hit his peak and it's gonna
start moving down but Mary yeah we
disagree on that we were having a lively
conversation about that before
talk about butterman then Trump I mean
Warren I thought her best moment was
that unauthorized video in the home of I
think it was Joyce Linehan where she
said that you didn't build this on your
own
you know we all paid for the roads we
all paid for this if you have a business
we contributed to your workers education
everything and even she during the
campaign was managed right so she dialed
it back a little bit and didn't look
comfortable at points especially in some
of the debates where she was coached to
do or not do certain things with Scott
Brown but once she got into office she
went back to being the Elizabeth Warren
you know that I think we all know and
that the the most effective politicians
are the people who talk like they don't
care they don't care if they're gonna
they don't care they're just gonna tell
you what they think and that's the most
refreshing thing to me because the more
you do that the more people like you and
most politicians and people who work for
them counseled the opposite you can't
say this she can't do that because
there's not gonna like it
right and voters are smarter than that
they know they know that Elizabeth
Warren when she talks she really
believes what she says and that's what
people like about Donald Trump he's
saying whether you agree with him or not
offensive or not a lot of people believe
and like the war would really put it
work that's that's why he's so appealing
to so many people right now and I think
Hillary's best possible move would be
this is probably the last time she's
gonna run cuz I oldest she's 68 alright
again yeah I mean if she wins she'll run
forever yes but but she won't she won't
run again if she does not win just go
for it say what you think in the they're
so afraid to lose and to the
taken out of context and to do that just
if she just relaxed and went for it
but I think you've been saying right
it's so hard when there's stuff on you
all the time and any little tiny thing
you do it can be blown way out I mean I
think this is a real pill well that's
why I did it's a strength for her that
she's been getting garbage from the very
beginning I don't actually I don't think
it hurts her feelings I don't think she
actually get she's like fine whatever
and if she can you know the more she can
say what she actually thinks what she's
actually planning to do and I do think
she's hitting her stride a little
because if you look at I think the great
example is the Benghazi hearings right
the 11 hours Benghazi hearings where
there couldn't have been a bigger
disconnect between Hillary Clinton and
what she said and the people on that
panel because every single one of the
Republicans on that panel
absolutely positively believed
everything they said and more about her
and the Democrats believe the exact
opposite of what they believe their
Republican counterparts and and she
believed otherwise and and and that
helped her more than anything but I
assure you that all the Republicans on
that panel will do very well in their
re-elections in their home districts
because that's what the people that they
represent believe and I think that's a
perfect microcosm of the politics that
we have right now
and even though I think that was
politically advantageous to her and you
could see it in the polling afterwards
by the way she handled it I mean they
kept baiting her every for I mean
everyone who questioned her even little
things that I think maybe some people
didn't notice like a number of the
Republicans kept saying well why don't
you read your notes from your staff now
let me give you a moment so you can take
a look at that note your staff just
wrote to you or prepared for you before
you answer that question I mean that was
they they had a number of stock lines
like that in an effort to diminish her
demean her or try to get her to snap and
if she had ever shown any anger during
those 11 hours like she did the first
time I assure you her poll numbers would
have dropped precipitously so though if
a guy did it it would have been
passionate
and ace defense and lots of other ways
to define it had she done it it would
have been a debacle hey yeah oh man I
think that is a moment to open things up
for questions from the audience so if
you have a question please just trot
right down to one of the microphones and
if you have to leave students who have
other things to do please feel free to
leave and don't feel uncomfortable so
what questions do you all have for our
panelists
I'll start people are shy about
questions when I think about your choir
this is very rich conversation so much I
want to ask let me make one quick
comment and then ask a question the
comment is that I think one of the
things that you implied Mara when you
talked about these wonderful novels
about a woman president is that is
something really important it's almost
always the case that popular culture
precedes actuality many people have said
that Obama owes his election in some
degree to the number of black figures of
authority that began to appear in
popular culture black football coaches
like Tony Dungy black presidents on
television programs things of that kind
and of course something similar is is
also the case with with with with
feminism and with the perspective we
have on female candidates and I'm sure
that your novels are among the the most
important items that are helping to it
reach an audience that pays no attention
to normal political discourse and that I
think that's really valuable my question
is this what I discern here is a Hillary
bias to put it mildly how about all her
negatives folks even those of us who are
eager for a female president are at
least some of us are incredibly unhappy
that she has to be the vessel of this of
this revolutionary event and it seems to
me important for the panel to
acknowledge in how many ways she is a
compromised and in some ways
less than stellar candidate and what how
tragic that is in an environment in
which the Republicans seem intent on
nominating an intolerable clown no it
doesn't sound like a question I guess
what it really is totally walk about
Hillary's about what's problematic about
Hillary and your own reactions on what
you think more broadly
Hillary is our card right now I'm a big
Elizabeth Warren fan and the person I'm
watching very closely although I hope it
doesn't take quite that long is a
Gillibrand I control brand would be a
fabulous president all the Hillary
people leave him sees you know if I were
making up a candidate to be our first
female president would it be Hillary no
not even close there are a lot of
downsides she's our best shot right now
she's our she's a viable shot I would
rather it when I said earlier people
said oh I'd vote for a woman just not
that woman you're gonna find flaws with
it that you the world me everybody we're
all gonna find flaws with every single
female candidate who shows up and
frankly I don't always agree with myself
so I certainly don't always agree with
everybody else I can change my mind and
middle burn arguments Hillary has a lot
of downsides there well cuz I'm very I
would show the truth you know yeah but
if you go back to the Clintons the
Clintons just they do their Clinton
thing they make us all crazy
I think deep down their little hearts
are in the right place and as long as
you give them enough trinkets
like you know the Clinton the Bill
Clinton years were pretty awesome peace
and prosperity I have to tell you they
were great they were fun we haven't had
that for 15 years
really Hillary's what we have we could
do better but how long must be wait we
should have had a female president 30
years ago we had we should have had a
female president if Jessica we should
always have had 5050 you know we haven't
and if that is who we can get in and I
think I like to do a pretty good job you
know there will be times if she wins
that she would drive me absolutely up a
tree and I hope it spouting on social
media about her
probably but she's smart she will work
hard and if you've ever heard her speak
a number of times in person and she's
that rare bird who speaks
extemporaneously in full pages not
sentences not paragraphs full pages on
any issue under the phone you're
thinking wow if you were guy she's
certainly 101 in 2008 without even hmm I
mean she would've and is that your
sister Mary Ann I think I think senator
Obama would have been vice president and
then he would be running right now in a
more experienced place and probably be a
better president than he has been I
think could be wrong over to you I would
just say to you um the topic is women in
politics tonight so there you go
and I would challenge you about Bernie
Sanders I would challenge you about
Barack Obama I know
okay that's the reality of it tomorrow
hold on let me just address what you
said I appreciate your question and
provocative but I think it when I listen
to you ask that question I'm
hard-pressed to think you would say that
about a guy is hard-pressed to put to
make a negative argument no I'm not a
candidate because there's no perfect
candidate
period because honey molar flow I don't
think in some rock obama that
shortcomings bernie sanders has
shortcomings john kerry who I worked for
four years had shortcomings I mean let
me go down the list all of them I mean
you know they Swift voted him okay I
mean let me go down the list so I think
you know so I just want to attend to you
I could give you a different example if
you follow New York politics at all I'm
a New Yorker
in our last mayoral race Christine Quinn
was running she was a stellar candidate
she was perfect for the job she had all
the right experience all the right
everything and you know what everybody
said I'd vote for a woman just just not
that woman and you're thinking what do
you want if we were drawing her up in a
lab we would have created Christine
Quinn to be the first female mayor of
New York City and it didn't and you know
it's she did the profile and glamour she
did everything she was supposed to do
critical of Hillary directly although
eye candy I think yes when I meant by
the fact that she's a compromised
candidate are the obvious things first
of all she's a Clinton how many times do
we have to have dynasties in the country
even if she was perfect in other ways
that would be a tremendous negative for
many people second something you people
aren't acknowledging most of the people
I know who really hate kill Hillary are
feminists and they hate come on my son
is probably my son who was my son is a
very extreme feminist he could mean he
believes that Andrea Dworkin is the the
most sense of a writer about politics
who ever lived and he represents he
represents I radically he represents a
radical extreme of feminism they hate
kill Hillary because she was an
apologist what they say she was an
apologist for a rapist
they hate Bill Clinton because he was a
rape he was a rapist they feel that
almost under no circumstances do they
want to vote for him now I know they're
a minority but they're on the left then
there are all these people on the right
who hate Hillary and hate the Clintons
for all kinds of terrible reasons right
that's all I meant by the fact that she
was a compromise candidate look I will
vote for her however many I vote for
almost there I thought for virtually any
Democrat in this environment anyway and
I certainly would prefer to vote for a
woman meant for a man for any office for
the reasons you people have made clear
and that any rational person accepts
what I'm saying is it seems to me a
tragic dangerous situation in which in
an election in which almost any not of
character a candidate I would say is
less compromised would have a much
easier time winning life and now what I
don't have why can't we recognize that
we're faced with a terrible problem here
because there's so many people in the
country who begin already knowing they
will never vote for this person because
everyone is flawed and when you run for
president you have a choice between
usually two sometimes three people all
right so all I would say is I've heard
this for years everyone can always tell
me how flawed a woman is and I can tell
you for a fact women are other woman's
worst enemies back and
every woman here knows this unless
you're like 18 maybe you were something
yeah that's what happens okay and that's
why we hold women to a much higher
standard yeah women do in men right and
I could go down chapter and verse but
I'm not going to about all the flaws of
we've elected every version of a man as
president United States okay we're about
to be on forty five they've been tall
short fat skinny white black Catholic as
Episcopalian born-again Christian
recovered an alcoholic let me go down
the list
okay we've we've elected almost every
version of a man almost not every single
time but pretty close and we've never
ever ever elected a woman now if you
wanted a better other woman should have
run I agree Chris kirsten gillibrand
phenomenal but using she has young
children she will run in about eight or
twelve years
there are lots there he lose to
substandard men who lose races on that
so is there a perfect woman candidate no
and Hillary Clinton is human like
everybody else so she's just like every
other candidate you know what here here
I'm gonna leave you on this point so we
can listen to somebody else I would ask
you to watch this video when it comes up
online and watch how you ask that
question talked about it and your
perception of her and then show me one
male candidate you would say the same
about its Rachel question hi thank you
guys for coming and speaking I was
wondering why do you think it is that a
lot of I feel like a lot of different
countries and you mentioned Canada as an
example have been progressive in the
sense that there's a lot of women
presidents and women Chancellor's and
heads of state why do you think it is
particularly America's case when like
women and women's rights have been an
issue across the world why is it that in
America's case it you feel that's so far
behind in that sense great question it's
it's a great question it's staggering I
think
part of it is it is still okay to trash
women yeah in America I wish it weren't
women get hammered women in the public
eye and no matter who let's take it out
of politics for a second Jennifer
Lawrence brought millions of people into
movies millions of millions of people
she has what two Academy Awards three
commendations but three nominations
because I don't think she got it from
when she was wrong she got paid
considerably less than Jeremy Renner who
was a walk through at a movie for you
know forget Bradley Cooper and the
others she got paid less than these
supporting characters I think in America
we're in this time of change where for
example with the passage of gay marriage
there are certain things that we're
moving for and obviously things with
race are moving forward and gender
identity and sexual identity and things
like that
that people are starting to talk about
and be less comfortable about it's so
okay to trash one right it's still okay
to say huh okay outfit looks kind of
static it doesn't and you know I think
because when you look at some of the
countries that have elected women some
of them are at least one is to my
knowledge Liberia is a Muslim country
yes at least one is a Muslim country
which you would not think would be a
good okay yeah so America I like to
think a little bit of a fan of
exceptionalism even though it's not
proper in global times but I like to
think America should be a model for a
world and we aren't and I'm embarrassed
by it and I'd like to see us do better
and do I have any idea why we don't know
but she is very right that no one is
harder on women than other women I think
if we're the majority of the population
if we really want to put a woman in
office we can do it how you treat women
is how women get treated
right so to your point about what it's
okay to trash women you people say
things about women that if you said it
about someone who is gay or
african-american or anything else would
be a hate crime okay but it happens
every single day we don't pay women as
much as men in the same jobs still that
is effect and why is Jennifer Lawrence
gonna get more money now cuz Bradley
Cooper said he's not going to do a movie
with her unless she does okay
I mean women's health care gets decided
by men not by women let's go the basic
fundamental things that women deal with
every day are decided by people other
than women even though women are the
majority so I think whether it's
questions that are asked some points
that are made or all that you need to
put yourself in that situation and by
the way on this earth for the most part
you're either a man or a woman you can
be an african-american woman you can be
a Latino woman you can be lots of forms
of women you give me lots of forms of
men but somehow women always come up at
the short end of the stick always even
though women are the majority in this
country and I think until women are paid
as much are represented in Congress in
political office and on s CEOs and on
boards that's not going to change but in
terms of thinking through like the
comparative question though right which
is like why is America doing so much
worse than other countries
I wonder right you know I wonder if we
could think about the history of the
feminist movement in this country and
what happened with the feminist movement
in this country and versus those other
places you know this might be a way to
start thinking yeah I don't know it's a
mystery if audience members have ideas
they should so the big the next book I
wrote this jumps slightly but it is a
similar issue is about a young woman who
actually is good enough to play
professional baseball boy does she get a
lot of garbage Wow people are not edgy
is good enough she's a 6-2 lefty that's
what you're gonna need
and a pitcher but you know in this last
year
the NCAA softball finals and the women's
soccer great victories got higher
ratings than the NBA Finals the Stanley
Cup and I forget what else not football
cuz you know Americans I watch football
- I have my Patriots hat right behind me
but you know you see women making these
little steps but so far behind
everywhere sports Hollywood a friend of
mine who is a novelist did a wonderful
book called Hilde if you want an
intellectual version of Game of Thrones
did a study recently about the
percentage of women winning the major
literary awards minuscule I just
miniscule even the number of female main
characters because most of the women who
were winning the awards had male main
characters or women directors there's a
big women directors remember and you
know I personally think even if we
picked a person as our female president
who not everyone's gonna love God had
changes everything if there's a trickle
down into all fields I don't care who it
is
which mom I really just want to go men
in the Oval Office in charge I think one
one point okay as a country founded
fleeing religious persecution a lot of
religions don't have women and as
priests or bishops or I mean I think you
if you look at some of the more main
religions that this country whether I
mean the Protestant church Episcopalian
Church is better about now but a lot of
this country is Roman Catholic and women
just do not participate in any level of
Catholicism in any leadership role so I
think that had a lot to do with it and a
lot of politics there were a lot of
Irish Americans and Italian Americans
obviously largely Catholic politicians
who ran and made politics their vocation
because they were shut out of other jobs
back in the day Irish need not apply go
through all of that so there's a lot
there's a real intersection between
religion and opportunities and how when
are used are allowed to participate in
religion and I think that had a lot to
do with the way politics unfolded in
this country I also think that a reason
why a lot of times women get more grief
than men and is is that at some level if
you can't persuade the next generation
to think of themselves as feminist if
that's a tough sell right that's a big
problem
right I mean like now we're willing to
say like that's racism that's homophobia
right but that's sexism is a harder
thing to get people on board with
sometimes I think there's been a very
effective campaign especially by the
right to demonize that word and a lot of
young women don't want to be associated
with that word exactly of the semantical
demonization of the word rate and I also
think that a lot of young women don't
understand that even women who walk out
of here in a few years will get paid
less than the guy you were in next to in
the lab or sitting next to today and
that won't change that has not changed
and it won't change for some time and I
think young women are idealistic like we
all were and I said you know thirty
years later I did not think we would
have made so little pile progress in
politics shocking stunning and
unacceptable so I think that's where
young women in particular need to be
vigilant about the hard-won battles that
have been waged fought and won and they
haven't been enough to make sure that
those things don't go back me what good
is it if you have reproductive rights
but there isn't a clinic in your state
to go to what good is it and that's
what's going on in this country
systematically so I think whether it's
voting rights reproductive rights it
okay if we're talking to me pay equality
is a major battle in this country that
women should get paid as much as men and
the only women who are guaranteed to be
paid the same as men our elected office
mm-hmm
that's it nothing else you know the
thing is we still haven't come up with a
good answer to your question why do
because nobody you know why have other
countries done it I don't know
we have to keep things but it's it's a
puzzle so I hope you didn't disappoint
you but that cuz America should do
better
we just sure so we have a question over
here maybe it's already brought up a
little bit but I was wondering I'm here
as a visitor I'm here as an observer I'm
not I cannot vote in that country I'm
coming from a very small and unimportant
country but our social science that what
I what I think for me it's impressive
and I'm following the debates is how
much religious topics come up and you
always know their religious affiliation
of the candidates in my country you
never know that and and for me this is
just something that I was wondering
about and also my question connects to
that what does religion do with the
question of gender and politics have you
already started to talk about that but I
would like to hear a little bit more and
also yeah if you hear it most often from
male politicians and less from female
politicians that they write books in
religious fields and or have an active
role in churches I mean it's also
because in Catholic Church there is a
hierarchy and the women are excluded of
course but in my country we have more
Catholics than in ever other
denomination and we have in the
Executive Committee there are in the
presidential committee so we don't have
a president like the United States but
there are more women than men so this
connection we don't I cannot make it
Mike why did think there are more women
than men yeah but why why do you say I'm
just curious it's like what what made
your country say we're voting for the
best candidate yeah because they they
were qualified to do that job
that's all it took where are you from
Switzerland okay there you go I'd go
back to I mean religion has always
played a role in politics and it's
obviously one of the big reasons why we
have the United States of America I
think a seminal moment in religion and
politics was when Jack Kennedy was
elected president United States he was
the first Catholic to ever win the
presidency Al Smith and others had tried
and failed so it was such a big issue
that he actually had to give a speech
about it and it was the biggest speech
he gave during the presidential campaign
in 1960 and it was because so many
people were suspicious of Catholics and
thought that President Kennedy if he
became president we take his orders from
the Vatican and the Pope okay fast
forward between 1960 and 2008 two things
happened one we started to have family
value voters and from Reagan forward
Ralph Reed the Christian Coalition
born-again Christians evangelical
Christians became major factors in
politics it was also part of an agenda
on social issues so social issues became
a very conservative wedge issue
especially around issues like abortion
that became major major issues in every
presidential campaign and US Senate
races in particular as well to try to
elect Republicans not Democrats into
that then that evolved to gay rights and
that was used as a wedge issue in a
presidential campaign in 2004 go to 2008
and Barack Obama Barack Obama belong to
church with a guy named Reverend Wright
Jeremiah Wright very controversial they
pulled a lot of his speeches and and and
sermons that he gave and Barack Obama
was forced to give a speech at
Philadelphia about his religion about
Jeremiah Wright and about the things he
said in his beliefs and that was
probably as important in his speeches
any that Barack Obama gave during that
presidential campaign and had he not hit
it out of the park on substance of style
you could argue he might not have been
so people abused religion in the United
States in politics not as much for good
as for getting elected and I think
oftentimes what you find is many of the
people who use religion as part of their
platform and a cudgel of sorts
oftentimes don't live up to it and
that's when people are practicing the
politics of hypocrisy but make no
mistake about it many political that
political use of religion has certainly
more than anything been used to keep
women behind and women are the ones who
paid the price for that more than
anything not only by not getting elected
but by having legislation and bills
passed that hurt them and I again on
social issues in particular so that's
the sad truth about all of this what you
would like to believe going forward is
now that we've made progress went and
still not enough on civil rights which
we still need to do much better on on
gay rights which we still need to do
much better on I think people have lost
sight of women's rights and when you I
will leave you on this note in this
country the fact is not only are women
the majority the vast majority of women
in this country support themselves or
their family alone because they're
either divorced single parents or they
outlive their spouse or partner so at
some point in this country every woman
supports themselves in somebody else and
so they rely on their paycheck period
women make at least $250,000 less per
person in their lifetime because they
get paid less and they take time out to
have kids so whether it and there's no
paid leave by the way here so they take
time out to have kids unlike in other
countries unlike other countries and
they lose to the workforce they lose
paychecks in the process they don't get
promoted and they don't get paid like
their co-workers so when you look at
women's rights in this country they are
everybody's issues there are family
issues and everything else because it's
women who ultimately end up supporting
their kids supporting their family
supporting themselves and oftentimes
elderly parents on their one paycheck
mmm Wow yes hi thank you very much for
this amazing conversation I have a
question about I want to go back to the
issue of feminists
and how to think about the history of
feminism and things like that so the
question that I have is to what extent
the women in politics not only Hillary
Clinton but other women are feminists or
recognize feminism as as something that
they should o to to their positions and
things like that because the history of
feminism in this country is very
interesting because it didn't go into
the organized state political
institutions it remained it remains it
seems to be outside it's like grassroot
movement and its sees itself as outside
of the state broadly defined
whereas in places like Norway as a
political scientist some political
scientists argue feminist political
scientist argues that the success of
feminism and the success that brought
more women to the Parliament was
directly due to the fact that the
feminist movement grassroot movement
spilled into the the institutions the
institutions of the state so I'm just
wondering the extent I think it's a
dream to have the grassroot movement
that wants to be outside of the state
because something that is outside of the
state seen as very free and not being
constrained by anything if there is a
way to kind of broaden it and and sort
of utilize the platforms that women in
politics have with the ideas and other
aspects of women women's movements that
remains vibrant and yet still outside of
the political they organize politics
when the er8 came around and they would
read the text of the AIRAID people and i
should be able to maybe you can recycle
I can't anymore but I can't remember the
exact wording but essentially it said
women should not be treated differently
by virtue of sex right let's just sum it
up that when they read that statement to
people vast majorities of the country so
of course when they say do you support
the ER a no no the area is bad no no a
feminists of a hate man or you know
whatever and then you know the dumb
everyone's walking around my t-shirts
let's say women need men like fish need
bicycles and whatever it just got so
ugly and unfortunate and you know I
don't hang out with men who don't
respect women
cuz I don't want to because if you don't
respect you know to me if you don't
respect women you probably mean to your
dog too and probably mean to your anyone
from a different religion anyone from a
different race anyone with a a dope my
sister she doesn't like these divisive
times she finds them very very stressful
and the things she keeps saying is very
simplistic but she's very bright she was
valedictorian at Williams I'm not saying
she died but she's why can't people just
be nice to each other it's not that hard
and the baffling thing about feminism to
me is why can't you know a lot of you I
assume are engineers were studying some
kind of science if you do it well I want
to identify you say one of you was i
okay he was a friend of mine who was a
studying at grad school in Columbia he's
developing this 3d printing thing to try
to create a new retina I don't know if
that can work but it's his research
thing and whatever do we want to
remember that he happens to be Chinese
is this the relevant point do we have to
remember that he's male no I think the
retina it's the cool point ID okay you
know and there's this thing in America
where we like to put people in boxes and
you know I don't want you to identify me
by a litmus test or my demographic I
want you to say oh there's Ellen now you
can say I like Ellen I don't like Ellen
but I don't want you to say oh she's a
woman she lives in New York she's you
know I don't want you to pull me down to
tiny little details in America we're so
busy
categorizing instead of just saying
there is a person and I think that's
part of what families have got so caught
up in just turmoil and stress and angst
and the sellers didn't like it much I
gotta say and that that really hasn't
helped I mean now I think when I talk to
people who are 17 18 guys seem to be
much nicer and much less like it doesn't
seem to be coming up in the way that it
did and so I think progress is being
made but another point I mean you're a
Equal Rights Amendment the most
difficult political thing to do in this
country is to amend the Constitution
nearly impossible but people felt in the
feminist movement in particular felt
that was the way to go right to try to
amend the the Constitution the United
States to ensure that women would be
treated equally as men I couldn't even
get it enough signatures in each state
to get the Constitution amended so and
that that that effort was going on
through the late 80s and still failed
there is talk again of trying to
resurrect it so to go back to your point
earlier one electing more women is going
to help that and having more women in
government in in elected office because
that's power okay I mean I would say
that about businesses and everything
else first and foremost but the the
economic argument I made just before you
asked your question is the way it's
really being spoken about now because
those are the facts and I think the more
people argue the economics of it and
then pass laws and legislation to ensure
pay equity to ensure paid leave because
those are family issues not necessarily
just female issues then that's more
likely to be
successful I mean disheartening to have
this conversation in 2015
depressing but that's politically that's
probably what has to happen and just
having more women in Congress more women
in the United States Senate and
hopefully a woman in the White House at
some point soon I'm very curious to see
what happens in 10 or 20 years because
all the numbers are saying there are now
more significantly more women in college
than men what's going to happen because
if you have more women than men getting
the graduate degrees and becoming the
doctor I mean just more I would have to
assume but there is gonna be one but no
yeah but this you know having the
running Wall Street running this running
that I'm not that they're gonna get rid
of men because of course they aren't but
I realize they could be coming out wrong
but we could move more towards parody
yeah I also think it's really
interesting to think about the history
of which issues got pegged as women's
issues and got a look at a lot of energy
around them politically and while I am a
big believer in women's right
reproductive rights and all these things
I think in a lot of ways the fact that
abortion became the issue was incredibly
polarizing and that unfortunately like I
feel like obviously the economics one is
a much more winning proposition right
it's hard to do not do you know what I'm
saying like yeah so I feel like it's
also interesting to look back at the
history and see what got traction when
and how that you know contributed I feel
like totally understand what you're
saying yeah I think a lot of women and
protect me tell me one procedure a guy
has that they have to go to Congress
about okay and I think that and so I
think many women thought if I can't
decide what I am going to do from head
to toe then that's pretty basic and yet
that's the debate we're still having I
know
I know I don't deny it but I think it
was I think it was problematic
politically in terms of other things not
getting done yeah hi thank you guys so
much for coming this have been really
fun
I have two questions and they're sort of
related and they're kind of more on the
representation angle of this
presentation one is I'd love to get your
comments on thoughts about quotas for
women in government I note some
governments around the world are
experimenting with that and curious what
you think about that and then on another
slightly different angle I write a lot
about representation of girls and women
in toys and books at for young kids so
I'm really appreciative of what you've
been doing on that and actually I'm a
former baseball player myself so I'm
gonna have to read that book that you
did so I'm curious if you talked about
your thoughts on whether things are
getting better in terms of specifically
political realm of seeing girls in
positions whether they're like the lead
character you know whether they're shown
in toys I you know I do a lot with
talking about girls in the STEM fields
but I'm curious if you talked a little
bit about your experiences and your you
know perceptions of whether things are
getting better staying the same I'm
getting worse in the last 10 20 years
well Geena Davis has her I'm sure your
yeah she's doing her big media project
which she came to I think mostly after a
league of their own
yeah I think she became very concerned
and she's saying I guess she had small
children and she looked at movies and
television and realized there are no
little girls in any of these scenes or
there's one little girl in the back it's
all little boys doing the things and she
got Hollywood to start Disney start
throwing in little girls so that it
could look more like the actual world
looks which would and it's sort of
shocking that that would be considered
progress but it is and I think toys now
you can
except I think it just came up with the
Marvel movies that there are no toys of
black widow doing anything interesting
I think Black Widow comes with outfits
and Captain America and the others come
with hammers and things and so that's
kind of depressing I'm sure your
research focuses quite a lot on that
kind of thing
well uh there's also like the book
Cinderella eight my daughter right which
is a really amazing book if you haven't
read it I really love it and one of the
things that that she talks about is hat
is that the Disney Princess thing is a
pretty recent phenomenon and that it
actually got worse in terms of how women
and girls were depicted in the 80s and
90s which is kind of interesting right
that in fact we had been making progress
thanks to feminism and then all of a
sudden we came to this cultural moment
where we started going backwards on
these things and it was nice to see
target saying that they were going to
stop doing the gender you know because I
think people are starting to really push
back against how pink and blue our
culture is thanks to you know peggy
orenstein and thanks to other people
drawing attention to this so hopefully
we're gonna try and reach wrench and get
better again but it's interesting that
we had that getting better getting
better getting better and then like
going backwards I mean I would I would
point to two things one South by
Southwest the hip cool going on in
Austin right in the gamers and the
bullying of women gamers yeah absurd and
yet their answer to that was to just
drop the panel both of them and it was
until Katherine Clark the congresswoman
from here who called them out on it and
recode and a bunch of other folks
started boycotting South by Southwest so
this is South by Southwest right the hip
cool happening everybody kills
themselves to go there because you're
supposed to be seen cutting-edge
technology design art culture politics
music all of it can't deal with the fact
that women gamers get bullied and I mean
savaged to the point where they feel
that their their lives are threatened
and their answer was to drop the two
segments until a woman congressman from
Massachusetts challenged them on it
so that's depressing on a slightly
cheerier though although I'll hijack you
a little bit here but I maybe play a
couple of war games online maybe kind of
actively and in that one of the war
games I've been playing for about seven
years and whenever I show up online
they're like how come you're not working
on your damn book yeah good point
but the interesting thing I play a very
aggressive war game called king of the
world where people are out for blood and
there can be some ugly male/female stuff
oddly enough I've been in the two most
were the number one Alliance right now I
used to be the other number one Alliance
and other play the male players started
noticing both these alliances were
totally female dominated in the
leadership the soldiers were mostly men
the leaders the commanders were almost
all women and we were the two because I
jumped from hitting into bounty hunters
we were the two top alliances in the
game and because a lot of smart people
play this game and it's a very social
game actually and people from all over
the world play there's a lot of talk
about isn't this interesting that the
women are like the fierce leaders of the
game and we never see this and language
started people started behaving better
when they suddenly realized oh hey
they're running they're running the game
here they're dominating this and you
know in my Alliance because three women
are the top players and the Alliance and
we have two guys on our it means as well
but look there's language you can't use
in our thread because we don't like it
and the guys are very nice about it
every now and then one of them will use
a questionable word and then when I
should say Ellen June Theresa is this
okay did I go too far
and you know because but there is all
kinds of the other game I play is much
more anonymous and
a couple of times there's a lot of
attacking I got attacked by a player and
he was the player was rank much higher
and so I just sent a polite note saying
you know is this really kosher for you
to attack a newbie Eddie was really
brewed to me and I wrote back to him
he's somewhere in England - I said you
know I'm a woman I'm rather offended by
what you just wrote this is oh it at the
leave was very nice about it but I
thought that's terrible that he would
treat anyone that way and then this
chivalry kicked him which isn't quite
what we're looking for I think we're
looking for equality not chivalry but
it's just my experience in games it's
just because I don't have any research
knowledge I don't have any theoretical
knowledge I just play the games and it's
been a you know a very strange
experience also I've done female Sports
report of photography and guys actually
doing this we had an event recently
where the Yankees were coming
it was autistic children like okay the
anchors come in Andrew Miller is gonna
be the big guy well of course I was
anywhere out of showed up suddenly male
reporters came from everywhere and
actually started hitting me physically
hit I'm standing there with the camera
and not gonna be done this and I'm
thinking wow this is a strange world we
live in that these guys think it's okay
to come and physically knock me down
of course I jumped in front of them yeah
said hey autistic children leave me
alone
but it's a very strange phenomenon of
this interaction within game and sport I
think it's much easier for everybody and
everything when you see people like you
in positions and things that you want to
do right so whether it's in pop culture
or books or TV or movies or sports or
politics if you see somebody like you
it's easier to imagine that you could be
that person didn't Madame Curie lead to
a bunch of female scientists it predates
pretty much everyone in the room but
wouldn't you think it would have it I
thought that MIT Simone would be able to
jump right in with an answer
that yeah but if we got the age but if
we had they put them right now a
political question I just came from a
meeting and given that Hillary will be
the Democratic candidate to running
mates were suggested that I just wonder
your thoughts on one was Elizabeth
Warren one was Deval Patrick disgust for
her for advice president yeah if she
were on the ticket for president you
know you'd like to think that two women
could be on the ticket the same time and
that would just be some mind-bendingly
exploding but Bill Clinton obviously did
something similar when he picked Al Gore
to southerners right and they thought
you couldn't elect two people from the
south
I mean I've certainly heard both those
names right but I've also heard
Charmcaster Julian Castro maybe Tim
Kaine Virginia somebody like that so I
think the question is in the general
election no one votes for Vice President
right you vote for who the president is
but oftentimes people pick a vice
president to address either political or
demographic issue they're trying to gap
so Obama picking Joe Biden was smart no
matter whatever Joe Biden has said or
done over the years it was smart
politics for him right white Irish
Catholic you know blue-collar background
all those things very helpful especially
at that point in the campaign when he
picked him I think all of them would be
great I mean it I think whether it's
felissa thwart or you know Duval Patrick
I put I don't think I put Deval Patrick
in the same now I put a Lizabeth Warren
first I would if I were gonna try to hit
that I'd go with Cory Booker myself
you know I think Tim Kaine gave me
things like that there'll be a lot of
options
Castro's obvious for obvious reasons
Latino trying to get Latino votes
I actually think Elizabeth Warren would
pull in a shocking number of votes even
though people don't vote for Vice
President Xi speaks to people right now
it like she's the right person for the
times I don't know if I were here it's
such a weird year but I would probably
blow the dicen if Elizabeth would say
yes but I'm not so sure she would I
probably go for it because Tim Kaine is
the sensible pick but I don't know it
would be a traditional thing yeah that
would be the that would be the the
obvious pick I mean I'm not sure
Elizabeth Warren doesn't bring a state
with her that you weren't already going
to get your but you just get this sense
of the plain speaking plain talking
it's what's drawing people to Bernie in
a passionate way because he's shooting
from the hip and she should you know I
think a fire Hillary I would roll the
dice and totally take Elizabeth Warren
if she could say yes and I would give
her an Al Gore level of power you know
I'd say here are some your income
inequality there you go
that's yours too you know I would do
that would it be smart politics it'll be
very very risky it would be entertaining
it would be exciting about your work but
personally I think it would be brave and
bold and really interesting so Ellen can
I ask you has all this an actual female
candidate as a final question is this
leading you to want to expand the
president's daughter series well you are
no I'm probably writing a sequel are you
yeah okay good but if any of you've read
the book there's a different main
character and it'll be late in the
second term fabulous so I can all look
forward to that yeah it's not imminent
but it's excellent anybody would be
gaming too much X I know I always get
cut yeah they always a now Mason what
are you doing you shouldn't be playing
the game any final questions from you
all
ready dream election no that would be
the end of the world as we know it
I would judge her as I would judge any
candidate in that I think before you run
for president you ought to have held
office it's a pretty low bar I think the
Republican nominee likely as somebody
who's not held office hey and if it is
someone who's held office I think she's
not an unlikely VP pick if her numbers
hold up
so maybe the really great Trump could
get the nomination I do you do yeah I
have for about two months now what and
can you say why so I think people have
vastly underestimated him and vastly
underestimated how angry people are in
this country about Washington and Wall
Street in particular and again I don't
agree with much if any of what he says
but I understand what he says and why
people find it appealing yeah and every
time I was on TV and everyone I was on
with including Republicans said oh my
god did you hear what he said that's
gonna cost him ten points he went up ten
points right so he eats much savvy er
than people are giving him credit for
number one number two when you look at
the polling everybody who supports him
are with him period of InnoCentive
sentence they're not looking at anybody
else when it whereas when you look at
ben Carson right I understand his appeal
especially in Iowa his book in his it's
been part of homeschooler curricula
curriculum for 20 years home schoolers
are huge in Iowa as are evangelical
Christians so I understand his appeal
and why he's doing well but his about a
third of his support his supporters say
you know what we could vote for somebody
else too so his supports more soft and
then if you look at every time Trump has
gone after another opponent you know Jeb
Bush I mean he smelled blood in the
water
Jeb Bush he's calling him a low-energy
and he has a very strategic savvy way of
getting the weakest point of his
opponent and going after it
and tipping him over and that was if you
watch that's when JEB really started to
tank right he's gone after Marco Rubio
he's gone after Carson he doesn't want
to knock out Carson he wants to knock
him down a little bit cuz if he knocks
him out up comes Ted Cruz and Ted Cruz's
the guy sitting there like a shark in
the water waiting for Trump and Carson
to just collapse which I don't think
they are but he's just trying to you
know he's the shark looking for the Chum
and he wants them to do it and he's
running out of time so I'm if Trump wins
Iowa and New Hampshire he runs the table
he's the nominee period understand no
one's gonna stop him you won't you can't
no one can stop him and and and I had
said shy I'm like sitting here shocked
yeah yeah well it's no surprise yeah but
it's but it but relevant to our
conversation when I on March 1st that
one of the things that he does the
terrible is sexism and as we've already
discussed this is one of them for one of
the free areas of American culture like
you can get away with it and also I
think I was very struck watching the
Democratic debates that Bernie Sanders
is put incoming inequality on the table
in a way that was so unprecedented I
feel like in the last couple election
cycles and you're sort of saying that
Trump is kind of banking on that same
level of anger about inequality right
right yeah I mean this is the Republican
primary process so you know women are
can be collateral damage I mean I did a
segment of Fox a week ago Monday and it
was about Carly Fiorina in the view and
how the girl and the women on the view
criticized her appearance in her face
and we're very they were terrible about
it right so i i'm not i'm i was very
critical of the women on the view
however i did take the opportunity to
remind everybody about what Carly
Fiorina said about Barbara Boxer when
she ran against her and her appearance
when she ran against her in the Senate
race you know five years ago and lost to
her so women are other women's worst
enemies right and you know you can't be
a hypocrite too so there's a lot of that
going on i what i what you're seeing
with Trump again people he's very shrewd
he's now bringing his wife with him to
the debates before it was his daughter
who's he's featured and many things
out in events his two sons accompanied
him yesterday to New Hampshire I mean
he's very methodically and
systematically rolling out his family
all these big events he's been doing
everybody's like oh he's just doing big
rallies yeah he is and you know what
he's getting nomination paper signature
so he's on every ballot in every state
in Texas in Alabama look at the places
he's done rallies they've got their
nomination signatures he's got a real
organization and he has spent the least
amount of money in the campaign and on
TV of anybody yet he's a front-runner so
I think again it's very easy to sit
there and say oh he's run a very smart
smart campaign and you may disagree with
everything that comes out of his mouth
but a lot of people in this country
agree with them yeah wow I hate that to
be the final conversation but I but I
feel 20 to 20 percent or 25 percent wind
you every contest in a 10 person race
right now and in March it's winner take
off I'm not talking I'm talking about
the nomination it'll be if it's Clinton
Trump it'll be a a Celebrity Deathmatch
pay-per-view and closer than do I think
that well if it is I think she wins but
I think it is an epic brawl see you're
giving me a better way to end okay yeah
thank you thank you very much and thank
you audience for coming